ce week-end c'était la fête du monde
animal sur l'hippodrome de vincennes à
paris des centaines de chats et de
chiens abandonnés ont trouvé de nouveaux
maîtres et pour donner un coup de pouce
à cette opération généreuse brigitte
bardot s'était déplacé le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que bébé n'est pas
passé inaperçu reporte à florence où
habite jean paul yacht ravir la vedette
aux animaux ce n'était vraiment pas son
but les une arrivée de brigitte bardot
ça ne passe pas inaperçu résultat la
foule qui se pressait l'hippodrome de
vincennes délaisse chiens et chats
pendant un bon moment
jusqu'à ce que brigitte la remettre dans
le droit chemin
on est là pour une cause bien précises
pour payer c'est la fête du monde animal
et que nous sommes tous là pour aider
les animaux aujourd'hui
alors n'oubliez pas c'est pas pour me
regarder qu'on est là pour aller adopter
un animal comme chaque année de
nombreuses associations de défense des
animaux se sont donné rendez vous pour
cette fête
buts doper le nombre d'adoptions de
chiens et de chats le ton de week-end il
y a ceux qui n'avaient pas prévu de
repartir accompagné avoir mon nom parce
qu'on aime les animaux est bon
envie d'un chien jours c'est l'occasion
qui fait le larron
et puis il ya ceux qui savent trés trés
bien user de leur influence trou où tu
vas mettre fin à bon si tu veux lui le
temps d'un week-end 200 chiens et chats
abandonnés ou retrouver un maître
l'adoption c'est d'abord un coup de
foudre